you weren't in season one of dynasty you
only joined in season two i went into
season they because they were trying to
get sophia loren
and elizabeth taylor and after sophia
turned it down then elizabeth turned it
down aaron spelling who i knew very well
um he stuck out for me and so i came in
and
when i was something 80 something yeah
and because you joined late is that why
there seemed to be a little tension
between you and john forsythe well
i think this shows how
the age of ageism in hollywood is i was
in my 40s when i got that role
um
linda was in her 30s john was 62. do you
think any of the press ever mentioned
that he was 62 it was always the older
women linda and joan you know in the 30s
and the 40 never mentioned it and i
would bring this up in interviews
because i don't like ageist people and
uh mr forsythe didn't like it
but he would say
why do you have to mention my age i said
because ours is mentioned linda's and
ours is mentioned all the time and we
want equality you know so if they're
mentioning ours you have yours and
there's a great clip in the in the
documentary of you at the people's
choice award when uh dynasty wins best
drama yes a bit yeah best um what is it
called uh ensemble ensemble yes and you
all go up and well we were told by the
publicist that when you go up on the
stage
john will receive the award now the
award is this huge glass thing have you
ever i'm sure you've seen of two pairs
of a pair of hands so we all went up you
know all in a muddle and we went out and
the girl was you know young
sort of starlet girl comes straight up
to me and hands it to me well you know
i've now got it so i say i want to thank
everybody for giving us this great award
and i want to thank all of our cars and
of course and also our fearless leader
and i tried to give it to him he said
she said enough and walked off
and he didn't speak to you how long
after that
a whole season
and when he'd be doing a scene where he
was supposed to try and strangle me i i
said i have
i have to have my stand-in because i'm
scared
[Applause]
[Music]
you